I look at our stuff the stuff we own is
sort of one of three categories so
here's part of the recipe there there
are the true essentials and I think
that's probably going to be similar for
most people it'll vary in size and scope
toilet paper yeah we're all gonna need
toilet paper we all need a roof over our
heads we need food we need clothing but
even those things vary right and then
there's the non essentials those are
things that add value to our lives but
but you could get by without them so you
could have a really bland life or you
can have these things that augment your
experience of life they enhance or
amplify your experience of life and
that's great then there's this third
category which should be the smallest
but I think it's the largest especially
in the Western world and it's junk
it's these things we thought we needed
right we thought we would like their
aspirational purchases its retail
therapy we sort of hear these words so
we'll buy the oversized orange
sweatshirt with tassels because it
looked really great on this mannequin I
got one of those all-in-one rice cooker
things it does like 30 different things
it doesn't work I don't know why I
bought it I'm talking about hot pot yeah
well that becomes aspirational right
you're like well because I looks like I
think I would get value from it but we
don't stop to ask ourselves will I
actually get value from and so we have
increasing amounts of debt in the United
States you know the average American has
$16,000 worth of credit card that has
four active credit cards and his or her
wallet one in ten Americans has 10 or
more active credit cards I was one of
them at 14 credit card because I'd be
stupid not to sign up for the Banana
Republic card right get 15% off this
shirt that I'll wear three times and
then of course you're compelled to keep
going back there and going further into
debt the aspirational stuff is is tricky
too because I feel like that is where
some mental burden like hits you this is
I have to one-up someone else I have to
you know have a better car and then I
have to eventually get a private jet and
then I have to eventually you know so
you're always trying to feel internally
like you don't have enough like you need
to be able to afford something bigger
and bolder
to make yourself seem worthwhile well
yeah I mean I feel like we all have to
have some type of purpose that we're
aiming for some kind of direction that
we're aiming for yeah and the things
that you mentioned one-upping are the
you know keeping up with the Joneses or
writing our friends or coworkers that is
one way to to to focus our time and
energy and our other resources it's it
like I said I think that is probably the
easy way to go just if you look at
evolution like being on top like that's
how you survived I mean at a certain
point like that was survival I think
that there are also many other ways that
we can still find purpose and we can
still find a direction to head in yeah
and the pursuits that that you mentioned
those are it's funny because we we are
raised being told that money doesn't buy
happiness but we all just want to try it
out for ourselves right just like for me
baby and the problem is that money sells
money problems and that's it it doesn't
really do much more than that yes it
does solve your money problems but there
are still you know problems or things
that you have to face with relationships
or with community or whatever it may be
so I think minimalism for me it really
helped me to refocus my my resources not
just my money but my time and that was
the number one reason why I got into it
is I saw an opportunity when I was
sitting there in that room with 80% of
my stuff still packed in boxes I just
thought to myself like I'm not buying
any of this like hey I would I would be
closer to being out of debt mm-hmm I'd
be closer to retiring early I wouldn't
have to work 60 70 80 hours a week to
maintain this this consumeristic
lifestyle so for me it was about I mean
honestly man I wanted to get to a point
where I was debt-free and I was able to
live off of baristas salary and for me
that sounded like and it still does I
mean one day I hope to get to that
lifestyle where I'm just you know
working 30 hours a week being a barista
but for me it was it was you know having
that 30 hour a week job but
the other time during the week to pursue
things that I really really loved and
that I really enjoyed
you